hey you can invite the awesome please
we want holidays when I think was
Brian's very invited you do yeah well I
was um at a very nice hotel in Turks and
Caicos and Bryan Ferry was also staying
there I knew him a little bit and Prince
was there as well Wow
this was a few years ago funny five
Brian said would you like to come over
and have dinner with Prince about what
this is a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
and so Graham yes of course about quite
a walk of conversation because Prince
doesn't say much I'm Brian Perry isn't
that talking in fact don't sort of sat
there nothing much to say and Prince
doesn't ask any questions he doesn't
know what do you do or you're my
favorite judge on Britain's Got Talent
20 and there's a magazine there was a
picture of Florence and the Machine and
I say oh gee you know just trying to
make conversation no frogs machine oh
but go no no don't no I said oh you know
she just did that that brilliant cover
of got dance song they watched our song
we know that one you know you got the
lover they were Prince what I don't I
don't know I know the song but you know
that song you got the love I need to see
you through
sometimes I've been singing embarrassing
looking at me black because I made up
this dog it was horrible oh and Prince
Ted it was that amazing sense of relief
really famous little if you just
definitely wanted to end so say that
you've met them but you wanted to be
over horrible but I had that with P
Diddy I went over to say hello to P
Diddy and JD was there and Leonardo
DiCaprio's acid all right then you've
dropped enough
[Applause]
Berry was good TV cause the people the
stories about I went over and I thought
I wish I think who these you target in
this scenario who's the one that you go
to to say the yellow and I'm thinking I
saw him in get him to the Greek I'm
going to go over there and say hello
teams I thought P Diddy so I went out to
shake his hand and I shook his hand he
just says are nice to meet he's going
huh but the longest time together and
I'm like that lady's looking impeded his
eyes like when is this going to end the
worst if it happened the worst happened
there was a whole thing with jay-z and I
went into leaned into speech him but you
can't lean him to speak to jay-z not
allowed to lean in and he's bodyguard
just like shove me like this and I went
to find across the room and I was like
well I'm just gonna go sit over here
with Eddie go thank you guys enough very
awkward moment that is weird that people
kind of live like that
it's so straight I have to say please I
know that people the the sometimes he
was right but I was very good friends
with it was none of my favorite now he
was so funny
[Applause]
though the got a strange sense of humor
you know like we'd go somewhere and he'd
say things like III would start going
for the food like I always do and I
would like try to get something and
she'd be very she's like he's an apology
would go haul my hands with sister stay
away from the buffet right I'm stealing
that that's why I'm sorry you didn't get
to week well I did get analyzed but
where we went it wasn't a buffet he went
to an all-you-can-eat buffets Prince
quite a smart hotel thank you thank you
very much
where Norton here if you'd like to see
even more stuff like that that hit
subscribe or don't the free world
but I know what I do in that situation